so thanks uh for the introduction and
for the invitation to talk here so we
going to be talking about experiments we
have been doing for some time with uh
this new device what it is what are we
trying to do with
it let me start with a little bit of
motivation and actually let me start
with a little bit of an anti
motivation um just so we don't have much
cognitive dissonance I guess so we find
no evidence of a Quantum speed up in
randomizing in
models and it's something that
we published uh recently in
January and we're looking at different
benchmarks now that there are reasons
why randomizing models might not be the
best place to try to look for a Quantum
speed up there when you say we find new
evidence of quantum speed up you mean
for the D machine in solving these kind
of problem correct ith it might be more
General than just a machine so just yeah
I'll talk a bit about what's going on
with this randomizing problems so might
you even if the princess machine you had
a Martinez machine maybe you wouldn't
find any speed up in this particular l
so I'll talk a little bit
about uh and also you know we're looking
at different benchworks now that might
be more interesting places to try to
find something in the flavor of a speed
up uh but still when we consider Uh
custom solvers designed for these
particular kinds of
benchmarks uh these solvers are
competitive to the kind of times we had
out of the dwa
hardware so that's you know an anti
motivation but so we still looking into
this uh well I guess I think that is
interesting to try to study what's going
on with uh controllable Quantum systems
when you have decoherence and control
errors dwa or otherwise you know at some
point you're going to want to get there
uh so you might say well thewi is
particularly noisy maybe there is not
nothing interesting there but I think
it's still worth looking into it uh to
see you know how much the coherence you
you can have until you see something
interesting or not how important May
control erors we are also trying to look
at the functional role of quantum
effects meaning you know so right now in
the D2 We have 9 of these
cubits uh and it's just you know it's
interesting to do one of these
computations that the do with Hardware
is designed to do and then try to see if
on the output we can still see any
choices or maybe not as much
entanglement but at least tunneling or
something of that sort and again that
might be more general you know like
we're using DW I'll be talking about DW
but if you have like a different design
of a different system and you put 500
maybe cleaner cuits together uh you know
it's still interesting to see if P plays
a role functional R in Quantum Manu even
if you have the CER and cont erors we're
also trying to study benchmarks where
you may see not necessarily an speed up
but faster than classical computation so
meaning even if you have a big enough
constant preactor so maybe you have
tunneling and you have tunneling of
let's say uh cunneling of 10 naring
cubits or maybe you there is some
algorithm you can cook up to simulate
that classically and it's just a
constant PR F of two to the 10 so that's
okay you know then we can try to study
what happens if you have more taling and
even though you can simulate Tel with a
custom prefactor if it's exponential at
some point it might be of practical
use um and you know we're trying to
design systems that if we find
benchmarks and Quantum effects that
might survive the coherence and play fun
a role maybe the current design of
thewave you know protype after all is
not good enough to satisfy the
conditions that might give us at some
point faster than classical computation
but maybe we can use what we learn to
design Alternatives and try to fix it or
thewave you know will try to fix their
designs and their cubits and things like
that to see if at some point we see
something that is faster than a
classical computer and generally
speaking although I'm not going to talk
about this at all uh I think it's
important to study
applications to look for potential
applications of artical uh Quantum
computation before we have like a full
blown up full tolerant quantum computer
with you know 160 million cubits and 10
billion Gates so we can do Source
algorithm so there might be something in
between where we are now on Source
algorithm or Quantum simulations is
another area I guess so I think that's
part of the motivation of why we are
studing these
things so let
me I had a question about I wanted so
study benchmarks for faster than
classical computation might be possible
well try to design systems that
Implement that
but so I was curious for your opinion if
you have
one
uh do you expect to find any Quantum
speed
up ever with the hardware that you have
now so by Quantum speed up you mean like
an exponential the speed up well or or
you know like a like a pre do you expect
to do with the with the hardware that
you're studying right now do you expect
something better than the result in the
first bullet point with different
experiments
uh it's you know it's hard uh so I'll
talk about that later and the thing is I
I do expect to find something that
simulated on in for instance that what I
expect to find to be able to you know
Define benchmarks which which are at
least a constant prefactor a significant
constant preactor faster than simulated
Anin but there are other algorithms and
I describe you know this algorith this
algorithm by Alex salby which is like a
large neighborhood search and there is
it might be more difficult
so we think that the the low dimensional
interaction graph is a l limitation and
it opens you to attacks from these large
neighborhood algorithms so that might be
quite tricky so you know so I I don't
know it's your n optimistic nor
pessimistic that you can improve with
the existing Hardware on what you have
in the archive paper well I think with
the existing Hardware right with
existing Hardware I think it's going to
be hard to find a significant speed up
yeah but you know we're we're still
looking around so we haven't you know
look at all possible H works but as I
was you know as I said the low
dimensional interaction ground
connectivity for simulated analing is
you know simulated aning I think we can
do things that simulat can really do and
I talk about that but these are large
neighborhood search algorithms or
ristics like the one that Alex sby
implemented that one is pretty powerful
and pretty robust so I have you know I'm
not going to talk about that but you
know I I do have like I design like a
problem which is specifically hard for
this particular implementation of large
neighborhood search uh meaning it took
you know this particular algorithm like
20 minutes and the hardware could do it
in like half a second so that's
interesting and you know I can probably
do random versions of of that algorithm
but then you can maybe come around and
change these you know implementation of
large neighborhood SE is just difficult
actually even the simulated kneeling if
I understood correctly from Troyer was
two different things one
was classic classical simulated nealing
and the other was think simulated
Quantum maning right yeah so passing the
Monte Carlo Quantum manil that one take
you know at 500 cubits with like 10
cores is let's say around 20 minutes so
if that was the competition then I think
that would be interesting because you
know if what I can do on the hardware in
20 micros seconds takes me 20 minutes
with 10 cores uh you know given that
this is still a prototype I will
consider that quite interesting so what
worries me are not you know time scales
in the and if you care about exponential
Speed apps then you know we're looking
at into it but you know trying to find
an scaling it's just very complicated I
don't know but yeah trying to find an a
different scaling of PA mon Carlo we
have some results that we're checking
and I'll show you at the end where it
looks like PA Monte Carlo is doing
something different than the hardware
and it might be because PA Monte Carlo
might not always tunel but you know it's
just hard for look to look for different
es scaling but still PA Monte Carlo is
minutes just go to the next SL maybe I
mean I think a lot of the talk is also
about your questions so can yeah I
didn't mean to make it an infinite
question I just
want talk okay so so maybe well start by
describing a little bit at the low level
you know what we're talking about just
very basically so we're talking about
these flux cubits in the particular case
of D you might you know cook up
different Quantum maning
implementations um what this flit is
it's basically some potential here is
actually the face corresponding to the
flag so you have some flag I'm just
dividing it's just units so this looks
like a face here just by my units uh so
you have this uh standard looking sort
of harmonic oscill potential this comes
from capacitance and this comes from
inductance of this uh electrical circuit
if you want but then you have Joseph and
Johnson which gives you this gives you
this cosine terms so that cosine terms
comes from the Josephson Johnson so then
if you look at the potential which has
this quadratic part from inductance and
the Joseph then you get the double well
potential and once you have this double
well potential then you can quantize it
and when you quantize
it then if you just keep the two low
energy states then you can call that a
cuid so those are the cids we're talking
about it's just the two low energy
states of this double w potential that
you get for this
uh circuit and you know the energies are
low enough and the the coherence is not
high enough so then you actually can
quantize it and see measure effects that
come from quantization so this is
something that has been known by a lot
of groups for quite some time
already uh so then we
have
uh this Sigma X term which correspond to
the taning of this double potential
maybe let me let me just explain that a
bit more carefully so we know what we're
talking about so we have this double
well potential
and I'm going to quantize in Flags I'm
going to say like if I have some Flags
which is localized in this particular
well I'm going to say that's fast down
or one and this is zero let's say plus
up so that's my quantization basis it's
on the FL axis here and just putting it
as current it's just changing the
units uh so that's my basis so if I tilt
this double potential with some bias
then I got I'm going to get an energy
difference between up and down so that
energy difference is my Sigma
C and if this barrier is not very high
then I can sort of tunel or have super
positions between the two Wells and
that's my Sigma xter so this Delta here
is the tunnel in between the two Wells
and the sigma C is just the bias between
the bottons of these WS basically so
with that I have my cubit so I can sort
of
trays um so if you if you can control
the Joseph and Johnson term which is
this coine term that gives you the
double well potential then you can trace
the T you can look at the magnitude of
your teling as a function of time which
is this blue line and you can look at uh
the bias if you have some bias between
your WS as a function of time which is
this green line so then you have some
sort of uh atic computation or in our
case an I'm aning because in atic
computation is supposed to be Crown
State and you go slow and never go over
the Gap but in in this particular device
decoherence and thermalization is going
to be very important so I'm going to
talk about aning because thermalization
might be dominant in some cases instead
of just this slow computation of the
current state so the point is that you
have this time dependent
Evolution uh and in the spirit of atic
quantum computation or Quantum manine
you can start with some uh your cubet in
the transverse field Direction which
just means a superposition between these
two Wells so you don't even have an
energy barrier and at the end you're
going to end up localizing one of the
two Wells so that's Sigma C so then you
have some evolution of your
cubid so that's the implementation and
these are the Nilan limes which we get
from this low physical potential on the
device that is at Nasa NASA Google
device so the design is a bit more
complicated on the main point here is
that there is an induct coupling between
the two
Cubs so then you have not only the sigma
X and sigma C term but this inductance
which is coupling fluxes gives you a
sigma C Sigma C term and you can also
control with some flag what is the magn
the magnitude of this inductance and
then there is some business here which
might be important but uh it's probably
not the Right audience for that so it's
a fairly complicated design but okay so
now you put uh let's say eight of these
cubits
together uh with this inductance cing
and uh and then you can try to see if
there is anything Quantum about them
let's say just eight of them so this is
from a paper basically a recent paper
basically from
thewave and the first thing you might
want to do is you want to see if you
have quantize energy levels and here you
have only two cubits so two of these
flat cubits with a mut inductance and
here you have eight
cubits uh so thewave is kind of limited
on the type of measurements they can do
because they have a design which is uh
supposed to be very scalable and that
you can sort of package and just install
somewhere and have other people running
things on your design and they filter
input lines there's there are a lot of
engineering restrictions that they sort
of go over to try to make it as scalable
as possible uh so it's complicated to
measure the energy levels more
complicated than either you know smaller
lab systems where you just control
everything that is going on but still
using this technique which is resonant
teling microscopy you can sort of see
teling between uh energy levels of Anila
and energy levels of your system so by
looking at the resonance we're just
looking here at resal Tes between energy
systems you can see that you have
resonances when the energies of this
illa that you're using to measure and
your system align so you can actually
see the energy levels what what it stand
physically here is a it's just a
different flux Cube it also couple with
an inductance is is exactly the same
design and what are they what are they
measuring I mean are theyum microwave or
I me uh it's slightly complicated
so you carefully choose the parameters
of the ancillas of of this one anilla
and you initialize it
down and the C okay so and it has some
local fields that you can change over
that's you just you just adjust the
energy of this bias of denilla and and
and it's coupling inducting Le to one of
the cubits in the system you're trying
to measure so at some point the energy
of the state of danila down whatever it
is an energy of the state of danila up
have the same energy just because the
the the way the coupling and the local
field of danila work so when that
happens you expect to see theilla
flipping from down to
up right because these states have the
same energy so you have maybe some
incoherence taning between these two
states so that's what you're measuring
here you're measuring the teling rate
between the Ancilla down state and Anila
up they're doing this by measuring the
probability that the ins is up at the
end of the time I me they're not
actually doing time resolved it's just a
certain time meure yeah so you you put
danila there for some fixed time you
keep the system fixed so the system is
not moving anywhere here you just keep
it fixed at what is the hamiltonian of
some particular time and then you couple
to danila and then you you know measure
thenila and you see if it's up or down
so you can get the tuning rate between
the up and down state and that's exactly
what you're seeing here tuning rates at
what energy so the color density is the
taning rate and this axis is the energy
that which you see the T rate and this
the energy of the local field of Nilla
so by doing that you see resonances
which corresponds to the energy levels
of your
system
okay so then you can see that there are
actually energy levels so these are two
cubits at least you have two cubits uh
here with it cubits you know maybe in
this particular State you don't you know
the resonance is not very good because
it's not just the energy being the same
but also the overlap between the states
but you can see resonances at higher
energies uh so it seem like you at least
have a level quantization and in these
two particular hamiltonians it turns out
that the ground state of this
hamiltonians is entangled so basically
if you just keep your hamiltonian fixed
at the hamiltonian that you're trying to
implement for some particular parameter
of uranine and you just let it
thermalize you know systems are supposed
to be thermalizing right this is coupled
to a is the coherent and as long as you
know if you're like here
uh well if you're thermalizing and this
energy gap is much lower than the
temperature then you expect to see most
most of the population in the G State
and if this G state is entangled then
you expect to have
entanglement so basically you can get
entanglement this way this way just by
getting the system thermalized with two
of these cubits and with eight of these
cubits so you can see entanglement with
a super conducting cubits even though
they are quite noisy so you see the
resolution of the energy L Is Not Great
although a lot of the lower resolution
comes from the you know Anila and
incoherent
but the point is you know just by having
a energy level quantization and letting
the system thermalize you're going to
see entanglement of f super conducting
cubits which is interesting so there are
some uh you know Quantum Resources you
can look for um but that doesn't mean
that once you're actually use it for a
computation these resources are actually
going to play any role so as for the
time the rest of my talk instead of
talking about these very careful
experiments I'm going to talk about what
happens when you put let's say 500 of
these cubits
together and then uh you dial in some
icing problem so you have some biases on
the flues and some neutral inductance
between different fluxes so you can di
some randomizing problem which and we're
going to be looking at cases where there
is no local field and the cins are
randomly plus minus one and then you're
going to see how fast you can solve this
problem and we think that is important
because this is an experimental device
like it's a prototype it's not only that
you have the coherence I forgot to
mention you know in the previous slide
from sort of the width of these lines
and and the width of the resonant line
of then seil on its own you can try to
estimate the decoherence time which is
around 10 NS just from these
measurements there are other things you
can try to do but let's say you know the
deance time is around 10 NCS what's the
T1 time well sorry I don't know I don't
know right now I guess it might depend
on you know the mes man but I think it's
of the same order of magnitude and this
is not a very precise measurement but I
think it's you know say more
there okay you know let's say 5 10 15 NS
we're going to be working you know at
time scales of 20 micros seconds I don't
think it's really important if it's five
or if it's
25 and it might depend on the cubid and
it might depend on you know how you
measure it but it's you know it's
l okay so your decoherence time is much
faster than the 20 microc seconds of
theing and on top of that you have a
control error so you you try to dial
some values for the muton inductances
but these are experimental devices and
their
fluxes going all over the place and the
thing that you're trying to dial doesn't
necessarily correspond to what the
hardware is actually understanding that
they're doing so there is some error of
around 5% and if we have let's say in
this particular case around 2,000
couplings if you just add this 5% error
in quadrat then you're going to get an
error which is order 10 where my energy
scale is of order one so you do have
like big control errors on top of the
decoherence so you might wonder if this
thing works at
all uh so then you try and it doesn't
work too bad so what I'm plotting here
is just for one of these random
problemin with the 59 spins or cubits uh
that we have in the hardware then I
repeat you know I just D this
randomizing problem I know the solution
because I can solve these problems and I
see how often the hardware actually
gives me the solution so what you have
here is the number of repetitions I have
to do and this is I I do this for a
th000 problems so the so what this means
is that 18% of the time out of these
1,000 problems I only need to do around
20 repetitions or less to actually find
the ground state okay so that's what
this plot means it's kind of a poor low
Decay but quite often you don't do that
many repetitions and you do find the
ground
state
so there are these gauges that you can
do
to remove some of these control errors
so most of my data will have these
gauges and it's just a way to assign
what flux up means zero or flux up means
one right so you can choose what flux up
means logically and that's my gauge and
by choosing different encodings then I
can average some possible errors and
then my if I do the average the
arithmetic mean of the number of
repetition s on different gauges I get
an slightly higher success probability
so often I work with this data but again
the conclusion is sort of similar you
know you you solve like around 70% of
the problem which less than that 500
repetition but with 10,000 repetitions
you solve
around in 16 gauges like 96% of these
problems so taking into account that
every one of these Anan runs was was 20
micros seconds and often I don't do that
many repetitions then you're in a time
scale of milliseconds that's pretty much
the point of this graph so basically in
milliseconds you can solve these
randomizing problems okay which is good
so
far uh you can try to an in for a longer
time and the probability of success does
go up so blue is 20 micros and is 100
microc and so you are more successful
either because you're more anotic or
because you're just thermalizing for
longer or for both of them but once you
take into account that you know if you
look at the time to Solutions so how
long it takes until you actually find
the solution to this problem when you're
and Le for longer even though the
probability of success T to go up the
total run time goes up because these
runs are more expensive and it doesn't
compensate the increas in probability so
normally we just run for 20 microc
because for
engineering constraints that's kind of
the faster we can go and I can tell
later why these 20 micros seconds but we
go as fast as we can 20
micros okay so so at least it's working
and you're getting the solution to all
these run randomizing problems in you
know time scale of milliseconds and
these are 500 spins so it's a certain
space of two to the 500 which is great
so so far it looks good but how hard are
these problems really if you use a
classical solver so this is something we
publish like year and a half ago in a
paper of something else and it's just
the runtime of some Exile solvers we
program and it gives you I guess an
upper bound on how hard these problems
are classically because these solvers
are exhaust and this time is
deterministic uh so TRS did one I did
the point is that um at the size that
we're at 52 spins I can find the low
energy of any one of these problems in
around what is this three minutes I
think it was okay so basically the time
scale for solve one of these problems
realistically was milliseconds but you
know an exact algorithm gets the energy
not necessarily the state out the worst
case time this is the worst case time
it's around 3 minutes so if you want to
look for some sort of a speed up you
have to look for it between milliseconds
and minutes I guess because you know
you're never going to be I mean if it's
more than minutes you're not interested
so you don't have a big range there so
these problems turn out to be even the
worst case whatever you know MP hard
problem you give me that you map to this
thing is not a terly hard problem I can
solve it with 16 cors in a few minutes
if you do the right algorithm these are
sort of except propagation algorithms
both of them in different slightly
different flavors okay so 3 minutes is
the upper time but now if you do a
simulated taning and you do a very fast
simulated tanine okay fast GE is not
important you just do simulated taning
and we're going to do a th sweeps so th
sweeps means uh spin updates per spin so
I'm going to touch every spin a thousand
times which is not that many and you
find out that for the same instances you
don't need to do that many repetitions
of simulated anine to also find the
right
solution okay and what is interesting
here is you only need to do 1,000
sweeps and 1,000 sweeps is the three
withth a square of this of the graph so
I have some interaction graph the three
width is if you want like the dimension
of this graph it kind of measures the
computational difficulty of the graph
and the point of this estatement
is um let's say it was like a completely
forom magnetic problem and these are
random problems and you have like just
one Def and you just want to get out rid
of it because I'm looking for the ground
state so you will sort of diffuse this
defa with simulated anine and sort of
the lower Bond on how many spin updates
you will have to do in the simplest
possible case is around a th because
it's the square of the dimension you
have to diffuse through so basically the
point of this is that if you do simulate
tanine in that you know with the minimum
number of sweeps and this is kind of the
fastest the sweetest spot for the r time
you also don't need that many
repetitions to find the ground state of
these
problems so I guess we been looking we
and other people at why this is the case
and why these problems are so easy for
simulated an and you don't need that
many sweeps and there are different
things you can come up with one of them
is this paper this recent paper by cut
Graber where he points out that the uh
spin glass face critical temperature is
set up for this particular interaction
graph and we've been looking with
Salvador and Alan from Harvard at you
know study of the energy landscape and
most local minim have a global Minima
close by and most of the energies ballet
so the energy that you have to go
through are lower around 4% of the cing
so it's another way of saying you know
understanding why you need that few
sweeps so now you have a fast
implementation of simulated
panine and a fast implementation means
you do in this case I'm looking at one
course see six spin updates per nanc so
you sort of parallelize your algorithm
and you're smart about what you're doing
so you are you know doing a spin update
sort of faster than the clock frequ
frequency uh and you multiply it well it
takes you to do one of these swps it
takes you I think for six I think it's
around 40 micros so it's around the same
time as the analing and you don't need
to repeat that many times so then you're
are again in the millisecond range so
then the run time for The simulated this
fast simulated an and the run time for
the hardware is sort of similar and I'm
not correcting here for this parallelism
meaning that the hardware is growing as
a function of problem size so you might
want to put a factor one or n which is
described in this paper we were at but
the point is that when you look at
simulate aniline this is the run time
for simulate aniline as a function of
problem size and the different colors
solid is simulated tanine this is one
CPU so eight cores and the runtime of
the uh of
thewave is similar uh this you know the
scaling looks different but it's because
mainly because I cannot run for less
than 20 micro seconds on anything
because of this engineering constraint
so basically
uh we don't see an speed up with
randomizing
problems although if you look it's
instance by instance you might see some
instances where your Hardware is doing
better than one CPU of simulated taning
and I was just looking now at problems
with plus minus one couplings if I look
at random couplings between minus 7 and
plus s i see a bunch of instances where
the hardware does better than simulated
and evening you know this fast
implementation in one CP you and so far
I was just talking about diling but then
you have to program the hardware and
things like that but even taking that
into account at Range s there are some
instances where the hardware is faster
than simul I you know this is not really
an speed up it's just some instances
you're doing better and it's still on in
the range of milliseconds but you know
for a prototype that's what we're
getting so now I'm going to talk about
the different problems which are not
randomizing problems and they may have
you know other interesting features that
might allow us to look into different
things like for instance simulator that
not
working um so but I'm not going to talk
about the speed I'm just going to talk
about uh
correlations so I wanted to to point
this out I was saying this at the
beginning so a lot of the benchmarks
we're going to be looking at simulated
tanine and least single split simulated
anim will have a hard time solving these
problems that's sort of by Design but
there is this large neighborhood
algorithm by Alex Al which is very fast
solving realistically almost all the
problems he put in Chima so this is
where why is difficult to do you know to
define a benchmark that will do much
better in the hardware than In classical
algorithms this is really a very R
algorithm and the way this works and
this is quite General so if you have
like a low dimensional interaction graph
so this is the way Kimera looks Kimera
is this graph of cubits in the dwa 2
Hardware whereas these dots now
correspond to Forest spins okay so
Forest spins here is one dot and then
these are the interactions if I just
group these Forest spins in one dot
so uh well there are interactions that
are missing because this will be like
sort of a 2d lice one on top of the
other but the point which actually so
here in light gray but not in the screen
the point is that in in this sort of two
the laes you can put one of these
trees so this is a tree without any
cycles and this tree covers 80% of the
spins in the interaction graph and
because it's a tree then you can do a
very fast you know conditional of the
value of the spins that are not shown
here so there's a spin there sort of
coupl to that which is not showing on
the screen but conditional to the values
of these spins I can minimize the
optimal value of all the spins in this
graph which are 80% of the spins and
because this is a you know a tree you
can do this with Bel propagation except
propagation if you want or transfer
mattics or whatever you want to call it
in around 80 microc in one core so
basically conditional to the value of
20% of the spins you solve exact L other
80% in 20 micros and when you do this a
number of times this is a large
neighborhood search then you know for
most problems you don't need to do this
many times so doing this many times mean
now I do a different tree and I you know
again do this very fast three
optimizations so from every point I see
like a very large neighborhood of
possible States and I see the global
minimum in this large neighborhood so I
do this a bunch of times often you get
finally to the ground stage
realistically so this is the algorithm
that is really hard to beat more than
simulated anding okay so with that said
how much time I have um 15 minutes 15
minutes okay so I'm going to switch
gears a little bit and I'm going to talk
about something which s to familiarize
with what sangu is saying is going to be
saying yesterday so uh which for us has
been a really important contribution to
the discussion so that's why I want to
talk about it
um so we're interested I'm not going to
talk about the speed here I'm going to
be talking about trying to understand a
bit more uh what is going on with 500
cubits so we have you know eight of
these cubits and it's as I saw at the
beginning if you're careful enough you
can detect entanglement in of these Cubs
but now I have 500 of them with some
random icing model or different sort of
Benchmark problems so I want to
understand how the hardware is behaving
if the entanglement is sort of
completely was up from the Cur or not or
there is maybe you know some limited uh
incent tunneling that may be playing a
role if there are like a small en
barriers things of that sort so I'm
going to try to study that by looking at
different numerical models which I think
in some sense are sort of you know very
crude approximations to what the
hardware might be doing so one is
simulated taning and I'm not going to
talk too much about this because it
turns out to be not a very good
approximation although it's very fast
for some for some problems and this is
just thermalizing classical spins plus
minus one so you might think you know
this might be a good model of the
hardware if really have forgot about you
know all these nonsense of cubits and I
just have my fla in the left or right
well and I I'm just thermalizing so you
can think of you know well then may
might behave like a classical an buo
then there is this other model uh this
path Monte Carlo Quantum vanine or
simulated Quantum vanine and this is
also a classical algorithm where what
you do is you map um sort of
thermalization in the transverse fizy
model it's just a mathematical trick you
map it to classical spins only in plus
one dimension so it's very similar to
simulated tanil because at then you do
still have classical spins but you have
to put one extra Dimension and it's is
still a classical algorithm
okay but something interesting about
this algorithm is that it allows you to
obtain values of some observables even
if the state is in Tangent so like in
the example I give at the beginning with
the eight cubits there are some
observables I mean it was a trivial
example because they were only CU so I
can just solve it but if I just run PA
Monte Carlo there are some observables I
can measure and even in my original
system had entanglement this
thermalization of classical SP in D
plus1 Dimension gives me the right value
for for those observ and so model that
we're looking later is this moding by sh
all which is going to expain later and
we call it spin B mon Carlo and we
understand it at least as basically
thermalization in product States so you
kind of have um your tuets and you just
keep track of the expectation value if
you want you start to mfield the spum
value of the poly operators so they look
like spin vectors and then you just
thermalize it so it's equivalent to just
thermalizing Pro state so nothing about
en so for this Cubit example this model
does not get the right value of some
observables but you know who cares right
because maybe you know at the range of
500 cubits it might not capture what is
going on right at the phase transition
supposedly but by the time we measure
after 20 microc seconds after the pH
transition mfield tends to work really
well so this model my work and it's not
my modelist since at
all okay so this is you know uh well
sorry it's not so very much here but
just trust me this is like upgraded
crafts or something we published uh some
time ago but this is now looking at s00
cubits and and the new dw2 instead of d
1 so we see that path Monte Carlo even
though it can be slow like it takes 20
minutes to do this points here instead
of you know milliseconds uh it does
correlate well with the hardware for
these randomizing problems so you know
maybe we can understand what the
hardware is doing and just
thermalizing some semil classical
approximation if you want maybe not semi
classical just
thermalizing uh you know these cubits in
some sense so it's just thermalization
and there is nothing else that's kind of
the motivation for this model and it
does correlate very well and this is a
classical algorithm Al there ler then
there is a spin meth on the car
which correlates well even with the new
hardware and I'm see talk that well okay
actually correlates really well with PA
Monte Carlo which is interesting so this
is I think you can sort of realistically
understand this as a neld vers a per M
and it it correlates well with the
hardware and this is not the result this
is its result and this is even more
classical than PA mon okay so that was
for random problems so now we're trying
to look at problems that I distinguish
better between uh these different sort
of uh numerical you know still classical
algorithms about hopefully to learn
something about um what's going on
physically with these 500 noisy CU so
one problem we have been looking at
lately is this cluster problem um what
we do this is the interaction graph of
these 500 Cubs here well I just looking
at7 of them I'm going to put uh for
these cluster so these are cubits in the
hardware that form a pte g I'm going to
put all the Cs forer a magnetic so they
have to form a cluster they're going to
be like they want to flip together and
then I'm randomly going to put a
coupling just like in one corner between
these
clusters okay and the RS of the
couplings in between clusters in this
particular case is going to be the
energy is going to be the same oh this
is between clusters and they can be
random plusus one and in the cluster
it's always minus one so the idea really
the main motivation for this is to
just um sort of have simulated T in half
a hard time at Le single spin flip
update simulated tanil so you can do
simulated tanil of this cluster where
you FP this clusterone go and it will be
different but then I could introduce
some
frustration and if I introduce him
frustration it might be hard to find
this cluster so it's just you know like
a initial step to try to understand big
difference between simulated and so
sorry again that this is not looking
very good but oh these are just
correlations of probabilities of
simulated t with 5,000 sweeps let's say
so I just run simulated t for 5,000
sweeps and I run the hardware for 20
micros seconds and I like look at the
probability of getting the ground state
so these blue lines where in this
127 cubits is the correlation for the
randomizing problems but then if I do
these clusters not surprisingly because
that's how I design it simulated T in
has a hard time flipping the whole
cluster but the Hardware sort of manages
to make the cluster point in the right
direction so then you see that at least
for these cluster problems the hardware
has not much to do with um single
simulated aning just because the
probabilities of get to the G state are
very different so looking at this
cluster you know you think well it's not
just
as randomly flipping thermally with
detail balance my flag in there on the
right of that's basically pretty much
what you learn from here and the idea is
again you know to to try to understand
what's happening at bigger scales and
maybe you know eventually try to this on
benchmarks where boy might see some sort
of limited speed up of some not even a
speed up but a pre Factor but then if I
look at Monte
Carlo with these clusters uh it still
correlates very well with the hardware
and I'm running P mon car a bit slower
than I Su maybe but the point is that
you know it doesn't really have problems
with this cluster so four four means
four cells by four cells 17
127 cubits and 88 is like the whole
camera some 59 cubits which are here and
you see that passing the Monte Carlo you
know kind predicts sort of reasonably
well the probability of success that the
H will have so then you can say well I
can maybe understand how the hardware is
flipping these clusters by sort of what
PA mon car is doing just sort of
thermalizing uh in you
know these
cubits um so but if you look at this
spin Monte Carlo model turns out thisin
Monte Carlo which is more meanfield than
PA Monte Carlo also correlates very well
with the hardware even for these
clusters so you see that the speth monlo
has not much to do with simulated anine
because simulated you know was like up
there in the corner uh but it still
correlates really well with what the
hardware is doing for these clusters
okay so that was one
Benchmark so then we are you know we
have been thinking well okay yeah and
and actually you know simulate uh PA
Monte Carlo also correlates well with
the spin bath from Monte Carlo so this
extra Dimension is not really necessary
you can just keep track of the meanfield
value for these cluster
problems okay so what comes next is work
in progress so you know warning uh we
haven't like finishing that checking
that everything is okay but you know I
think it's interesting to sort of serve
where we are so we're trying to find
problems where the hardware might be
doing something different that has been
met from Monte
Carlo
and our thinking is well we started
thinking about you know what would you
expect to see if there was really like
Celine or at least limited caline we
don't expect you know like the 59 cubes
to just cotan all over the place but you
know maybe just eight cubits or two
cubits what what would you expect to see
if there was actually like physical
celing in the hardware
so we design a problem several problems
so this is one version where we by
Design uh Force the hardware to try to
Cel that's kind of the idea so this
problem is just we put all the
cins uh for a magnetic all over the
place and then randomly we choose the
local fields of these cells to be
pointing up or down and and it's
important that the fields the local
fields are slightly lower than the Cs so
why
these local Fields so there a whole 8
Cubit thing is either when it's blue
it's plus and it's red it's exactly yeah
all of them together so that you know so
they sort of form a cluster and they
want to sort of point in the same
direction and it's all of them
together so the reason why we do
that is because
um well initially just so happens that
if everything was properly calibrated
and we're not completely sure about that
but you know
there a range of local fields for which
this thing
happens um the local Fields sort of
dominate initially so if you have a
cluster and the cluster starts to order
to magnetize in some direction either up
or down the energy corresponding to the
local field is linear in this order in
the magnetization and the coupling
because will be you know the product of
the magnetization of two couplers is
quadratic in the magnetization so
initially when the magnetization is
small the the local Fields dominate so
basically the local Fields can trick you
to go in the wrong direction even though
when The Final
Answer should be dominated by the Cs the
local Fields can treat you
initially oh okay so then you know these
are this is some uh classical study of
what this energy do and we see this
bations point this is a bation point of
a high energy state but these are like
vations the discontinuous line so this
is just trying to study it's basically
it's a big spin model but it's kind of a
semi-classical mfield approximation with
biggest spins so what is happening with
the hardware so we're going of study the
energies and we see
bations of the energy scale and this is
you know it's a very small Gap but this
is where this tunneling happens if I
focus there this is what with V milans
by the way uh then I have like
some ground estate which is coming from
the beginning which corresponds to just
everything pointing in the transvers
field Direction action uh but then there
is some minimum that starts forming
somewhere else which is kind of
different from this which is the one
dominated by the cins which is kicking
out later and this one is dominating so
far but this will eventually become the
global minimum so you might get dropped
there and you have like not a very high
probability to jump to the other side so
then when we try this with a spin B on
Monte
Carlo uh then we see that there is no
correlation
whatsoever uh so this is a spin B from
Monte Carlo and this is the hardware and
the hardware tends to find okay so
probability zero been car is that and I
haven't checked all the energies here
this is kind of work in progress but the
blue is size 59 so there randomly you
expect to get the situations it doesn't
always happens because these are random
instances but basically it looks like a
spinto Monte Carlo is indeed getting
trapped in these states which are
initial local Minima and don't go
directly to the final Global Minima okay
whereas the hardware you know has a
higher probability very high in some
cases of finding the ground state of
these
problems
so P down on for reasons that we don't
quite understand sorry so your C is
where you have the opposite initial
fields are all within theet of the D
have you tried overlapping to see if you
have any Co tunneling between um no this
is pretty much like work in progress so
we yeah no we you know we're going a
step by step um and this you know we're
checking because we're worried about
calibration problems so this is where we
are now until we you know I completely
understand this including possible
calibration errors then we're not you
know I guess we're we're focusing on
this right now so do you have like a
histogram of the success probability for
the hardware so does it is it still by
model for these cases in the sense that
it succeeds on well yeah it looks you
know like there is high density there
high density here for the
hardware at 500 yeah so you know not
much in the middle okay so you know the
histogram is just the projection in that
access well I'm passing the mon Carlo
also that's quite bad for reasons that
we don't quite understand so maybe you
know there's really like tunneling here
I'm think that Monte Carlo just doesn't
tunnel well enough or maybe something
else in the hardware that we really have
to be careful about we're working on
understanding that so in particular
we're worried right now about the local
fields and the couplings not being
completely in sync in the hardware for
just the way the hardware is designed U
so we're looking into that
um but there are the there are other
problems that are less dependent on this
particular calibration problem between
local F and cins with like this fast
slow claster problems and it's just the
same idea but now the teling is done in
a different way so in this problem what
we have is we have a fast cluster and by
a fast cluster we means I put very
strong local fields and very strong
couplings in this cluster so as you go
along the aning this cluster orders
early on it just you know it just has
this strong c local fields and it really
knows where he wants to go then I have
this cluster which is a slow
cluster uh with a local Lo uh weaker
coupling and weaker local field and this
cluster you know sort of orders also
because there is not much frustration
except this little tiny thing has some
frustration uh you know so it will order
but it
orders a bit later it doesn't order as
fast as this cluster so then we have
this di in the middle so it's just a
strongly couped pair of cubits which we
call the B conection and basically what
happens is is forom magnetically coupled
to both of these clusters and these
clusters are going to want to order in
different
directions uh but the final ground state
this capl is stronger than this C so in
the final ground state these diers will
have the same magnetization as as the
slow cluster but because the fast
cluster orders sooner initially the DI
orders with the fast cluster you know
because the fast cluster actually has
some magnetization before and to make
things confusing enough for the dier we
actually take this Cubit and we make a
local F in the BR Direction so this
particular anchor Cubit orders even
later which actually tends to be
important for the numerics so this kind
of plays a ro but the idea is simple the
idea is that initially we want to order
the DI in the WR Direction Direction and
we achieve that by sort of making it go
in the wrong direction with this fast
cluster such that the for the ground
state it really has to go a different
direction but because it's a dimer and
it's a strong
couple then you know it might have a
problem going from one orientation to
the other and one thing that is not very
good about this problem is in all of the
problems I show you before all the
couplings are local Fields were plus
minus one and often we have clusters so
that makes the control error short of
not very important but here we have like
a range of couplings we are trying to
dial different like minus 7 but minus 7
gets mapped to the same highest energy
which is just physically the highest
energy in the cubid so that means that
these values are like relatively very
small so then the the control error here
is not 5% relative to minus one relative
to minus one you know is uh
35% whatever so it's high so you know
these things are in the hardware this is
going to be very noisy we try to stay
away from that but you know it's just
what it is so if we run pind mon Carlo
pind mon Carlo do really well on these
problems I'm sorry that is kind of not
sh that well there and the hardware is
not doing as well as PA Monte Carlo and
it might be because of this you know 35%
relative control errors on where the you
know minus one energies are pointing to
but but there it is so we're kind of
studying the control erors in this
Benchmark now passing down mon Carlo is
doing actually better than the hardware
but what is
interesting is that then if you compare
with the spin bath from mon Carlo even
with control errors which make the
probability is not very high this is
again the blue one is again 9 and the
red one is much smaller 127 and even at
127 you see you never get to one uh but
the spin B on Monte
Carlo uh even with control errors you
know it's closer to sort of probability
so speed met Monte Carlo is doing
something quite different here than PA
Monte Carlo and the hardware is are way
in the middle so we're you know and
again the whole theme Here is sort of
try to see if we can observe at least
tunneling even if it's just two Cubit
incoherent tunneling is a starting point
at the end of taning and then maybe with
this try to design benchmarks that you
know might give you maybe a constant
speed up uh even before we increase
connectivity so I think I'm kind of on
time of uh yeah so thank you and these
are different collaborator for different
parts of the talks but Google is a lot
of the numeric computation called har
we're working with from
NASA from Harvard Mohamed an from Ian
from the he's like the head physicist
that helps us quite a lot and people
from USC and E some some of these papers
that we publ Rec so thank
you
question
Greg if
you interruped you
answer can have a new
question uh but it's not very close to
your
talk but it's about the same machine
that so for instance there was an
announcement that says Quantum Computing
Contender helps refine Google
glast
and it would be the one that you were
studying I I don't know who uh how
should I interpret announcements of this
sort with care what with care yeah so I
don't think there was an
announcement with that wory never made
from go that's I was just reading the
headline from where were you reading the
headline New Scientist yeah so that's
not goodle so you know don't trust
everything you read on your scientist I
guess
so I can tell you what it is there's
aough you know Google Glass you know on
live but you know Google Glass is like a
real product and it's you know there we
have to be you know Google wants to be
careful about so you know I guess we
don't want to talk too much about Google
class because they do their own PR and
whatever they think I can say that um
but really what's going on is
um um you know you're being recorded I
know yeah that's why
to you know and it's not my thing it's
like the Google class people you know
it's a product so they you know they
they care about what happens to the
product and that's part of the reason
why we don't talk about whatsoever but
really what happened is there was an
algorithm a machine learning
algorithm uh which is related to Google
Glass and is designed to be
implementable in Quantum alen in general
and the dwa hardware you know as a
potential possible implementation so the
algorithm is designed for
the algorithm but it's a classical
algorithm now how that St being
portrayed new sentence or not that's you
know nothing I control of but it's a
classical algorithm designed to be
implemented in Quantum and it just
result to be a very good classical
algorithm so is if you want a Quantum
inspired classical algorithm so I'm just
thinking about and I think it that
relates to like the last point of my
motivation you know I think it's
important to try to think of things that
you might be able to do at some point
you know not necessarily now with the
wave two or maybe maybe not even3 or
whatever Hardware you know algorithms
that might be implementable in Quantum
anine or a different Quantum gravitation
Paradigm which is not necessarily full
Toler Universal Quantum computation and
one of these algorithms turns out to be
you know just classically by itself a
pretty good
ma
okay yeah um you said a little bit about
the control eras um I I guess um have
you have you considered the possibility
that what you're seeing is artifacts of
really um you know that um that um uh
what you're seeing in these in these
problems that you're
handcrafting uh are really artifacts of
control errors on your on in the D
machine and that if you were to add
these control uh control errors into
into the into our classical model that
you would actually recover exactly the
same things so we're working on that so
we already you know added the control
errors I'm sorry yeah we're we're we're
already you know added control errors so
we already do a modified algorithm to do
that this is you know like just pretty
fresh as you probably know because
there's like newest stuff even from two
weeks ago so we haven't collected the
data yet but yeah we're doing that and
not just you know even control errors I
think control errors might be important
on on you know the second Benchmark that
I so we P the Monte Carlo that's better
than the hardware uh but there are other
things which are more
systematic uh that we're looking into
for instance the a possible delay
between the local fields and the cins
and and we understand from like the
design of the hardware where the delay
might be coming from you know it's like
physically motivated systematic control
so you know that's something else we
have to incorporate in the algorithm so
you can never be S but we're working in
that direction so we're we you know like
looking at um new calibration of the
hardware and you know we have like two
different problems in one of them the
one with the bones I don't think there
are this particular delay between c
local this is important in the previous
problem this delay might be
important uh so you know these are like
now two slightly different benchmarks
that have at least a slightly Sim
feature but yeah you know this is not
finished and we have to look into all
those things yeah right and then there's
you know there's another there's another
way we can we can think about you know
as you are searching for examples
there's a there's a different way one
could try to calibrate classify them you
know one way one could you know you
could you could either try going towards
more quantumness or less
quantumness so so what I mean by this is
one thing you could do is um for example
uh go in the direction of turning down
the coupling strength or increasing the
errors so so not that that was what you
were trying to do here but but
inadvertently by increasing the range
what you were doing was what the the
effect it had was increasing the control
error so let's let's consider that as
you know classify that as going towards
more more classical problems and so so I
think you know one one thing that might
be useful is is sort of saying look um
we found a we found a class of problems
which distinguishes what the DV machine
is doing from this from this uh uh you
know from this classical model that that
you know from such and such classical
model but then it would be it would be
interesting to identify you know in
order to do this distinction did you
have to make the machine more classical
or less classical you know so it's if
it's while going more classical that you
you're are distinguishing then it's sort
of should point to the fact that maybe
maybe the classical aspects of the
machine are not being well mod right
yeah so as you know you know thewave D D
sorry completely different people Daniel
is not the but Daniel uh group uh I
think the first other W the actually
from UCL from UC uh they put a a paper
which I haven't mentioned here but uh
they do distinguish right right
right yeah I guess that's what inspired
the question so so is you know is is uh
do do you know whether this is in it
butly you know sort of you know that's
why I was suggesting such a
classification to try to understand and
where each of these problems is going
towards and um I think you know the
controllers are certainly more important
when I increase the range because
basically the one is not a one anymore
is really like a one over seven
physically and the and the errors
themselves didn't want anywhere right so
in that sense it's more classical than
the other things I was saying before uh
but you know we're it's working progress
so we're putting errors into the model
and and we'll try with you know in the
numerics and we'll try with different
ranges first and but I think
nevertheless I mean it might be
something else right but the theory that
is inspiring what we're doing here is
having this energy virus like in the
landscape that I saw at the beginning
and sort of trying to get into
situations that or maybe just like
energy level quantization maybe just the
low energy level if your quanti it just
has support in both places there's not
even taling they are like sort of close
enough that you know the low energy
state is just spread in both of them
it's not even taling but
that's what is inspiring me but you know
we're working on it I think in this
particular case what we think is that
you know it's suggestive of either
teling or maybe quantization not the
errors because you know it's this dimer
thing but you know it's it's work in
progress so we're looking into it
now uh concerning these control errors
you also expect that that gets worse if
you run you know imagine that if you
scale up the number of Cubit you want to
run the antia algorith from a longer
time but it's also known that the energy
level splitting of these cubits varies
over a longer time I mean I know this
also for transport cubits so the control
errors you know like in order seconds
they can vary in the sense that I think
people know that for the other
superconducting cubits you have to
recalibrate these cubits every so often
now you can't Rec calibrate these cubits
during your ad competition so is this do
you are you in contact with the people
from d-wave do this C these kind of
scale issues
or
um yeah you know for most of the stuff
we have done so far the control errors
themselves we haven't looked too much
into control errors let's put it that
way so the more we look into it but
every night there is some sort of
calibration going on uh so it's just
every night okay there is a little bit
of calibration it's probably more of a
cruit calibration but you know other
people would do with transforms where
they have more right but of course this
is the if if your running time is 200
mic you're not you don't have to
calibrate during those 200 micros
seconds if you say my running time is is
3 hours or something because it's a very
big system then and I know this is going
to be an issue for the other
superconducting cubits too they have to
take them offline to recalibrate them
and put them back in the competition so
there's this 10f noise yeah exactly and
you know so it's something that has been
messed or certainly there and you know
it's included in this 5% so it's there
and I think the one is not the dominant
noise I think it was like sort of
3% or you know the 5% is an accumulation
of Errors including one over F right uh
so yeah that's there and yeah we so we
don't M or you know we don't try to
compensate for one over F no so these is
there also thoughts about how whether
one can use this kind of system as a as
a purely
classical um you know of course it
solves a classical problem but but for
as a decoder on top of you know other
really really Quantum superc conducting
cubits you know I mean there other
things that you can do potentially with
such a system right it's I mean there is
a question of how you're going to do
decoding of uh on chip decoding on the
super conducting cuit and they probably
mainly requires a fast
logic that's a good idea I don't know I
don't know if anybody has been thinking
toward the sles I think you know just
classical super conducting uh logic is
interesting on right like uh this
reciprocal Quantum BL for instance is
exciting and you know it's kind of
similar underline technology guess there
there are actually a lot of single flx
logic in this chip to you know control
the devices most of it is this dig
converter which is perfectly classical
and they're just trying to control the
flaxes yes uh so it is but no certainly
I'm not thinking about that I think it's
a good idea I don't is thinking about
that I think it's a good idea
right let's uh thank s
again